[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
then
it was
became obvious that i was looking at a
human torso jurors get their first look
at the graphic evidence in the murder
trial of chandler halderson and the
latest twist in the lorry vallo day bell
story it's the state's understanding
that this court had reviewed that
in making the determination to keep the
protective order in place with regard to
mr means plus weeks after her guilty
conviction elaine maxwell's defense
wants to be back inside the courtroom
why a juror's past could mean a new
trial and later one year ago today
in this sacred place
democracy
was attacked the latest developments in
the january 6 investigation law on crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law on crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin for the first time jurors in
wisconsin are shown the graphic images
of bart hardison's remains this as his
son stands trial for the murder of his
parents prosecutors say 23 year old
chandler halda said it murdered his
parents 50 year old bart and 53 year old
crystal holderson in july 2021. they say
he lied to his parents about attending a
technical college in madison wisconsin
and about receiving a job offer from
spacex prosecutors argue that the
defendant killed both his parents when
his father discovered he wasn't enrolled
in school after that they say hollerson
cut up their bodies with knives and saws
and attempted to burn their remains in
the family fireplace days later he
scattered other parts of their bodies
across southern wisconsin before their
remains were discovered halterson
reported his parents missing to police
and told a similar story to wisconsin tv
stations on wednesday the state called
bart hardison's brother brett halderson
to the stand prosecutor andrea raymond
ended her direct examination with
emotional testimony from the witness
when was the last time
you talked to your brother
bart it would have been the morning of
july first
is there any reason you remember that
date
um
because
that's my birthday our family
makes it a ritual of contacting each
other on our birthdays
and that was a phone call that he had
made to me that morning
is that the last time you spoke to your
brother yes
no further questions
on thursday jurors were shown graphic
photos of bart harderson's torso from
the first time they heard from dane
county sheriff's officer
detective brent baberstock who
discovered the human remains last summer
you see the scrapes on the log there
just under the moss and then
you can see the pile of sticks there and
there's something underneath it
couldn't quite tell what it was right
away so
i stepped over the log and got a little
bit of a closer look
and what did you find
i didn't know what it was at first
i mean by that
it just
it took me a while to process what i was
seeing you know it
um
then
it was
became obvious that i was looking at a
human torso
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney nima romani and terry austin
nima in a case this graphic do you think
there's a line between showing the jury
too much gore and not enough and if so
do you think the prosecution struck a
good balance
i think the prosecution did brian i'm
all about shocking on these types of
cases you have an individual who's so
sick and twisted he shot and killed both
of his parents and dismember the bodies
after he was unable to burn them and
scatter them into two different
locations so you don't want the jurors
to feel sorry for chandler you want them
to identify with these victims who lost
their lives because they were pushing
their son to go to school and get a job
so i like what the prosecution has done
here they've really painted a story of
someone who's not only a liar
but who is
mentally unstable and capable of murder
on top of that terry the victim's
brother and the defendant's uncle
provided emotional but also some very
logical testimony as to when he last
spoke with his brother explaining it
like this
when his brother went missing now how
was that direct examination
you know i think mitchell holderson did
a good job on his direct examination
he's the older brother by 18 months and
while he was a bit stoic he did serve a
purpose he described the fact that his
parents were hard-working his father was
an accountant a mother was stay at home
and she nurtured both of them so they
were very good they didn't gamble and
they took their work seriously so i
think he was able to establish that they
were great parents no reason for them to
be killed and frankly his brother is a
ruthless murderer and it must be very
difficult to testify about your own
brother yeah provided a lot of
information there now to texas where a
man who's facing wrongful death lawsuits
after shooting his girlfriend's
ex-husband during a fight on his porch
is asking the case to be moved to a
different county he says he won't get a
fair trial where the case is currently
filed
in november karthu shot and killed chad
reed during what investigators believe
was a custody dispute and it was caught
on camera the video appears to show reed
and his ex-wife the girlfriend of karath
christina arguing on the porch carreth
goes inside his house and emerges with a
large gun that's when reed grabs the gun
and pushes kareth off the porch
video footage then shows kereth firing
two shots at reed killing him carrot's
attorney says that the claims the man
had no other choice but to use deadly
force to defend himself and his property
reid's widow jennifer and his mother
jinx filed lawsuits against kereth in
december kareth has asked those cases be
paused until a criminal investigation is
complete
this week on brian ross investigates the
inspiring story of a man diagnosed with
als at just 37 years old with two
children under the age of three chief
correspondent brian ross is here to
explain how his diagnosis is making a
difference brian
thanks brian coming up this week on
brian ross investigates a profile
encourage the story of a young man
diagnosed with a disease that was
supposed to kill him years ago but brian
wallick and his wife sandra have
persevered defy the odds and as
president biden said about them turned
their pain into purpose the entire world
was in front of them
perhaps a run for elective office home
in illinois at home in illinois
or working for this white house
raising two beautiful daughters
until everything changed
the coughs
the cramps the twitches
brian and saunder are joining us today
virtually
i say hi to you both
because they turn their pain
into purpose that's coming up this week
i'm brian ross investigates on the law
and crime trial network brian
thanks brian you can catch brian ross
investigates every tuesday and thursday
at 10 30 p.m eastern time here on the
law and crime network
still ahead on law and crime daily on
the heels of her guilty conviction
elaine maxwell's defense team says she's
entitled to a new trial
but first the latest in the so-called
doomsday duo saga how laurie valor dave
bell's former attorney is causing waves
in her coming trial
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back a new development in the
case of harmony montgomery a little girl
who's been missing since 2019 but was
only reported missing last week
harmony's stepmother caleb montgomery
now faces a welfare fraud charge the new
hampshire attorney general's office says
montgomery collected more than fifteen
hundred dollars in food stamp benefits
for harmony after she disappeared in
2019. harmony's father adam montgomery
faces a second
degree assault charge for allegedly
punching harmony in the eye in 2019 he's
also charged with endangering the
welfare of a child and interfering with
custody kayla montgomery plead not
guilty and her bail was set at five
thousand dollars cash new hampshire's
department of health and human services
declined to comment on harmony's case
when contacted by law and crime saying
the agency had to protect the
confidentiality of families it serves
police in new hampshire are still
searching for harmony and trying to
figure out what happened to her
the so-called doomsday duo mother lorie
valo dave bell's legal team goes before
a judge for a hearing to discuss her
former attorney who was recently taken
off her case
law and crime's terry ossin joins us now
with the details out of the hearing
brian mark means was recently
disqualified from representing lori
valodebel after it was revealed he
previously represented her husband and
co-defendant in the case chad dabo now
prosecutors want to ensure he won't talk
about the case publicly lori and chad
dabell are charged with several crimes
including first degree murder in
connection with the death of lori's two
children joshua j.j valo tyler ryan and
chad's first wealth
tammy dabo valo is now represented by
james archibald who was previously
appointed as co-counsel during a hearing
on wednesday the judge prosecutors and
valo's attorney discussed concerns about
mark means access to privileged
information that could be disclosed
fallow listened to the hearing by
telephone prosecutors requested the
hearing to ensure a previously sealed
order includes mark means but they
stopped short of requesting a complete
gag order the court determined that the
order covers current and former council
including mark means
we want to make clear we're not asking
for additional restrictions under idaho
criminal rule 16
we are only asking to have that remain
in effect whether or not that's just
clarifying that it does remain in effect
or whether or not it needed to be
extended or expanded to remain in effect
but we're not asking for additional
restrictions outside of what are already
in place with regard to the disclosure
of any discovery materials or
information so the order which was
issued by judge watkins on
july 15th
and looked at the terms of that order
the order
as it's written
i think
serves to
be in effect
as to
both mr archibald and mr means
lori and chad dabell's case is scheduled
to go to trial in january of 2023
thanks terry let's bring back criminal
defense attorney nima romani and terry
austin to dive into mark means impact on
the doomsday case terry what do you
think the impact of all of this is going
to be on the day bells a trial hasn't
even started but could there be a claim
of ineffective assistance of counsel
you know i think that laurie
particularly is going to claim
everything you can count on that she's
going to claim ineffective assistance of
counsel i mean so far she's effectively
delayed the trial by claiming that she's
incompetent and although insanity is not
a defense in idaho they can assert the
fact that she is mentally ill so she
wasn't able to have that intent that
men's raya so i think they're going to
pull every trick out of the bag to
defend the case as much as they can
nema is or should mark means have a job
after this could these be violations of
a lawyer's rules of ethics
brian it's been one ethical violation
after another for means and the irony is
he tried to get the prosecution
disqualified in this case but let's look
at what he did he has an actual conflict
because he was advising chad when the
search warrant was executed where they
found the children's remains in the
backyard he violated the attorney
witness rule when he himself testified
to laurie's incompetence and of course
he's not even death penalty qualified
there in idaho so we shouldn't be
handling this case anyway i mean nima as
you talk about it i'm getting flashbacks
of the npre and just shaking like so
many things wrong this could be an npr
question down the line
what as to what not to do as a defense
attorney thank you both coming up on law
and crime daily president joe biden
delivers an emotional speech on the one
year anniversary of the january 6 attack
on the u.s capitol plus could recently
convicted socialite elaine maxwell soon
see a new trial still ahead why her
defense team says a second trial is on
the way
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily a
family and community are mourning the
loss of a north carolina state trooper
after his brother who was also a trooper
hit and killed him and another driver
during a traffic stop it happened monday
night in rutherford county an hour west
of charlotte james horan lost control of
his patrol vehicle while he was
approaching a traffic stop he collided
with his brother john's patrol car which
was parked on the side of the road he
hit john and the driver he detained who
were standing near the patrol car both
drawn and the driver were taken to the
hospital and died because of their
injuries the north carolina state bureau
of investigation and the state highway
patrol collision reconstruction unit are
investigating
onto new york federal court where
lawyers for elaine maxwell will ask for
a new trial after a juror in the case
told reporters he's a survivor of sexual
abuse juror 50 granted at least two
interviews in which he said he discussed
his experience with sexual abuse during
deliberations with other jurors it's not
clear whether the juror disclosed the
abuse on his questionnaire he told one
outlet he breathed through it
prosecutors alerted the court to the
issue wednesday and requested a hearing
but maxwell's attorney said in a letter
that a hearing wasn't necessary because
a new trial was warranted based on the
juror's statements alone maxwell was
convicted on five of six counts last
month relating to sex trafficking young
girls she is a former girlfriend of
convicted sex offender jeffrey epstein
juror 50's lawyer has not responded to
law and crime's request for comment
here to explain the possible appeal
issues in the maxwell case is criminal
defense attorney nemo romani and co-host
terry austin terry what are the
arguments you suspect maxwell's team
will raise and are they strong ones
i think they're fairly strong brian the
defense is trying to vacate these guilty
verdicts they're claiming during
misconduct and actually they have a very
good case
two jurors have now said they may have
been victims of sexual abuse and they
did not mention that during their
questionnaire and they discussed these
experience during the deliberations and
in fact one juror was trying to convince
the rest of the jury about his
experiences saying that he believed the
witnesses even though the witnesses
might not have remembered everything and
frankly they're not supposed to serve as
experts there's a good chance that this
really could be vacated now nima can we
actually see a new trial or could this
be a strong negotiation tool for maxwell
to seek a better deal
i think we will see a new trial and this
is why the department of justice you
cannot give elaine maxwell the break
especially after what happened when alex
acosta was u.s attorney and he gave jeff
epstein that sweetheart deal where he
barely served any local time he
obviously died never received the
criminal justice that he deserved so you
want to do right by these victims even
if you have to retry the case if you're
the u.s attorney's office that's what
you do to finally bring some closure for
this really heinous sexual abuse ring
that took place over decades
all right we may be seeing then a gi
lane maxilla charge uh coming up and
maybe a trial part two will of course
give you updates as this argument for a
new trial continues when we come back
one year since the january 6 attacks an
investigation is still ongoing the
latest from the january 6 committee and
president joe biden's comments on the
one-year anniversary
welcome back to log in crime daily
thursday marks the one year anniversary
of the january 6 2021 insurrection in
washington d.c where a mob swarmed the
u.s capitol in an effort to overthrow
the results of the 2020 presidential
election
one year later the so-called january 6
committee is still investigating the
attacks most recently contacting fox
news host sean hannity about the
incident as long crime daily has
reported messages between hannity and
several other fox news hosts were sent
to former president trump and then chief
of staff mark meadows condemning the
attack the committee has also been in
contact with former vice president mike
pence who certified the 2020
presidential election results they say
he is cooperating with the investigation
on thursday president joe biden
addressed the attacks saying it was a
threat on the foundation of america's
rule of law
the will of the people was under assault
the constitution our constitution
faced
the gravest of threats
outnumbered in the face of the brutal
attack
the capitol police
the d.c metropolitan police department
the national guard
another brave law enforcement officials
saved the rule of law
our democracy held
we the people endured
we the people prevailed
for the first time in our history
a president
had not just lost an election
he tried to prevent the peaceful
transfer of power
as a violent mob breached the capital
but they failed
they failed
on this day of remembrance we must make
sure that such attack never never
happens again
what do you make of the investigation
into the insurrection now that a year
has passed and what grade would you give
it
brian i would give the department of
justice a solid b and this is why
they've done a good job identifying
almost all the people that unlawfully
enter the capitol building using social
media some of them were stupid enough to
stream it while they were breaking the
law and snitches and also they've gotten
to the next level folks that weren't
there but that were leading the
insurrection the proud boys the three
percenters the oath keepers the reason i
don't give them an a is just the slow
pace of the us attorney's office now
obviously federal prosecutors they're
not used to handling this volume of
cases but i would have expected at least
one or more of the cases to have gone to
trial
after a year
anniversary of the capital rights right
i think some of the trials are coming up
i think maybe in a few weeks so let's
see if they can get an a in your books
terry your reaction to president biden's
remarks did he hit the right point in
the proper tone for the seriousness of
this anniversary
brian he absolutely hit the right point
and the proper tone his remarks today
were the strongest to date on the
subject while he didn't mention trump by
name he definitely referred to the
former president multiple times and one
of the things i think he was trying to
do is to basically set the stage for the
next presidential election he's trying
to say that he is the right person for
this country and trump is not trump
cannot put himself above the law which
is one of the things biden was saying
that trump was trying to do here and
basically he cannot keep attacking
democracy we all have to make sure that
we protect what our country is standing
for which obviously is for democracy and
we cannot allow this to happen again so
one of the lines that he said that i
thought was really good is that you
can't put yourself above the system and
you can't love your country only when
you win
all right powerful lines to end there
thank you terry and nima and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you